Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Beim 1. FC Kaiserslautern gibt's mal wieder ein bisschen Chaos und diesmal könnte es sogar bis an die Lizenz gehen. Wie, wieso, weshalb, warum? Das erklärt uns gleich Sebastian Zobel, SWR-Redakteur und FCK-Experte.
Hi, Max.
Schön, dass du mal wieder im Rasenfunk mit dabei bist.
Ich freu mich auch wahnsinnig mal wieder dabei zu sein.
Ja, die Freude ist ganz meinerseits, denn ich weiß bei dir, ich habe einen Experten des FCK bei mir. Du bist nicht nur beim SWR da viel unterwegs, sondern hast auch das Buch geschrieben, 111 Gründe, den 1. FC Kaiserslautern zu lieben. Die alle bilden wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen das Gegenwicht zu den aktuellen Entwicklungen, wo ich gar nicht so genau weiß, Sebastian, wo ich eigentlich anfangen soll. Die Sache kam bei mir auf, als der Hauptsponsor, Harald Leinberger, bei Facebook-Einträge geschrieben, in dem er, Zitat, denjenigen, die sich wieder einmal selbst verraten haben, dicke, eitrige Pickel ins Gesicht wünscht. Und da dachte ich mir, oha, das habe ich von dem Hauptsponsor vielleicht noch nie gelesen. Also, Sebastian, was ist los beim FCK?
Es ist, wie du sagst, es ist gar nicht so leicht, einen Anfangspunkt zu finden, wo man einsteigt in diese ganze Geschichte. Was man mal festhalten muss, und das ist ja, denke ich, auch einer der Gründe, wieso du jetzt wieder drauf aufmerksam geworden bist, die Außendarstellung des 1. FC Kaiserslautern, die ist zurzeit eine absolute Katastrophe. Sie war es in der Vergangenheit ja auch schon das öftere Mal, aber im Moment ist es wirklich eine absolute Katastrophe. Wie du sagst, der Hauptsponsor mischt sich öffentlich ein, tut seine Meinung öffentlich kund, der Aufsichtsrat ist zerstritten, da soll angeblich der Aufsichtsratsvorsitzende abgesetzt werden. Es muss ganz, ganz viel Geld her. Das ist das Grundproblem beim FCK schon seit Jahren. Es fehlen jetzt um die 12 Millionen bis März, damit man die Lizenz für die nächste Saison bekommt. Diese 12 Millionen müssen jetzt irgendwo herkommen. Das ist der Kernpunkt, um den es geht. Wo kommen diese 12 Millionen Euro jetzt her? Das heißt, da gibt es verschiedene Überlegungen. Zum einen, der FCK hat vergangenes Jahr auch ausgegliedert, ist man auf der Suche nach Leuten, die Geld geben. Zum einen ein größerer Investor, aber auch Firmen oder auch Privatpersonen können da einsteigen, Anteile erwerben, eine zweite Möglichkeit wäre eine Art Zwischenfinanzierung über verschiedene Banken. Oder, was auch eine weitere Möglichkeit wäre, wäre eine erneute Fananleihe. Da hat der FCK ja schon mal eine aufgelegt. Die ist jetzt allerdings dann auch bald zur Rückzahlung fällig und dann da noch mal eine neue aufzulegen, um die alte abzuzahlen. Man weiß es nicht so ganz genau, ob das wirklich sinnvoll ist.
Ja, ähnliche Ideen hat ja der HSV gerade im Norden, aber die sportliche Lage unterscheidet sich dann doch ein bisschen. Also der HSV ist abgestiegen in die 2. Liga, der 1. FC Kaiserslautern ist abgestiegen in die 3. Liga. Da ist man aktuell so im Tabellen-Mittelfeld beheimatet. 11 Punkte wäre es zum Relegationsplatz. Das heißt, mit dem Aufstieg in die 2. Liga, mit dem Wiederaufstieg wäre jetzt nicht direkt zu rechnen. Ist das auch der Grund, warum jetzt diese 12 Millionen Euro fehlen oder woher kommt diese Lücke?
Das lässt sich gar nicht so ganz einfach beantworten, Max. Es liegt natürlich darin begründet, dass der FCK einfach sportlich seit Jahren auf dem absteigenden Ast ist. Ganz klar. Es gibt viele, die geben noch dem ehemaligen Vorstandsvorsitzenden Stefan Kunz eine große Schuld, der da angeblich gemisswirtschaftet hätte, viele Millionen da auf irgendwelchen Wegen ausgegeben hat, die keiner so wirklich nachvollziehen kann. Da gab es sogar jetzt eine vereinsinterne Prüfung vor kurzem, wo das noch mal genau analysiert wurde, diese Jahre unter der Führung von Stefan Kunz mit dem Ergebnis. Ja, moralisch gesehen war da nicht alles so ganz sauber, aber es gibt keinen Anhaltspunkt, um ihn da irgendwie wirklich haftbar zu machen für was, was er gemacht hat.
Da passt er perfekt ins Fußballgeschäft.
Also klar, der Hauptgrund ist natürlich die sportliche Talfahrt. Und wie du sagst, es ist natürlich auch nicht abzusehen, dass der FCK so schnell wieder aus dieser echt verflichst harten dritten Liga rauskommt. Das haben natürlich alle gehofft, dass es nur so eine Art Zwischenstation wird, dass man jetzt ein Jahr sagt, okay, wir gehen diesen bitteren Gang in die dritte Liga und sind dann in einem Jahr später wieder oben in der zweiten. Aber so einfach ist das nicht. Und wer sich mal mit der dritten Liga beschäftigt hat, der weiß, was das auf finanziell so ein hartes Brot ist und dass man da, wenn man da mal länger drinsteckt, gar nicht so einfach wieder rauskommt. Und ja, klar, es hat natürlich jetzt am Anfang der Saison ganz gut begonnen. Es war mal wieder so, dass man gedacht hat, Mensch, jetzt geht mal wieder so eine Euphoriewelle auch bei den Fans durch. Ich war auch vor Beginn der Saison im Trainingslager, habe mir das angeschaut, habe mit vielen, vielen Fans gesprochen. Trotz dieses Abstiegs in die dritte Liga ist man da wirklich mit mit einer großen Motivation in diese dritte Ligasaison gestartet, weil man sich, sage ich mal, auch in den letzten Zweitligaspielen ordentlich verabschiedet hat, obwohl es dann am Ende eben nicht gereicht hat, wenn man abgestiegen ist. Aber man hat sich ordentlich verabschiedet und hat dafür gesorgt, dass eben noch mal so eine Euphorie wirklich gestartet wurde und hat dann tatsächlich auch beim ersten Spiel in der dritten Liga zu Hause über 40.000 Menschen im Stadion gehabt, hat 1-0 gewonnen gegen 60. Und man hat gedacht, Mensch, das ist es doch. Genauso haben wir uns das alle vorgestellt. Jetzt blasen wir hier die große Aufholjagd, beziehungsweise das war der Status in einer tollen Saison. Ja, und Puste kuchen. Danach war wieder ganz lang gar nichts. Man ist so ein bisschen im Mittelfeld verschwunden, schon eher mit Kontakt zu den unteren Plätzen. Ja, jetzt nach der Winterpause zum Glück mal wieder ein Sieg für den FCK. Jetzt merkt man, es ist wieder so ein bisschen euphorie da. Aber man muss das ganz klar sehen. Meiner Meinung nach wird der FCK dieses Jahr nichts mit dem Aufstieg zu tun haben. Da braucht man sich keine Illusion hingeben, auch wenn die jetzt ordentlich spielen und vielleicht auch durch den neuen Trainer Sascha Hildmann irgendwie zu einem Team geformt wurden und jetzt auch die Wintervorbereitung ordentlich gelaufen ist. Aber da müsste jetzt echt schon viel, viel gut gehen, dass sie da noch oben in Wölzchen mitreden können. Allerdings lasse ich mich da auch gerne lügen strafen, aber ich glaube es nicht. Und deswegen, weil es nicht abzusehen ist, dass der Aufstieg kommt, ist das Geld eben echt ein großes Problem.
Okay, das kann ich natürlich verstehen, dass ein so ein Abstieg wirtschaftlich hart trifft, denn du kommst mit Zweitligastrukturen in einen Bereich, in den du wesentlich geringere Einnahmen hast als vorher. Jetzt ist das ja aber beim 1. FC Kaiserslautern auch wirklich keine Neuigkeit. Also ich habe das Gefühl, das zieht sich durch die letzten 20 Jahre, dass man immer wieder Geldprobleme hat. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass da schon die Politik ausgeholfen hat, dass die Stadt, die Kommune ausgeholfen hat, dass Sponsoren eingesprungen sind. Und 12 Millionen erscheint mir auch relativ hoch. Wie kannst du dir erklären oder wie kannst du mir erklären? Dir hast du es bestimmt schon erklären müssen. Warum gerade so viel?
Naja, der größte Batzen davon ist natürlich auch die Fananleihe, die zurückbezahlt werden muss. Und ja, warum ist das so viel? Da muss man tatsächlich auch nochmal ein gutes Stück zurückgehen. Wir haben vorhin kurz über die Ära Kunst gesprochen. Wir müssen auch tatsächlich bis zur letzten Meisterschaft, 1998, zurückgehen und auch unter die Tage, Jahre, bei denen Atze Friedrich den Verein geführt hat. Da ist man 1998 sensationell als Aufsteiger deutscher Meister geworden und hat dann plötzlich wirklich geglaubt, man ist jetzt auf einer Ebene mit Bayern München. Also in Kaiserslautern hat man geglaubt, man kann auf Dauer mit den großen Pinkeln. Und genau das war einer der größten Fehler, die man in der Vereinsgeschichte gemacht hat, weil man hat auf zu großem Fuß gelebt. Man hat Spielertatpflichtet wie Juri Djorkaev, der einen Heidengeld gekostet hat. Da streiten sich, glaube ich, heute noch die Arbeitsgerichte in Kaiserslautern drum, ob da alles mit rechten Dingen zugegangen ist. Es wurde ganz, ganz viel Geld unter der Hand als Handgeld bezahlt. Also da ist Geld rausgeschleudert worden. Ganz viele Allstars sind dann nach Ende der 90er, Anfang der 2000er immer mal wieder Allstars zum STK gekommen. Die horrende Gehaltszahlung bekommen haben, wie zum Beispiel an Mario Basler. Man hat sich dieses Millionen-Grab irgendwie selbst geschaufelt. Man hat zu lange auf großem Fuß gelebt, bis man dann irgendwann gemerkt hat, verdammt, das klappt irgendwie doch nicht. Falsche Transferentscheidungen, viel Geld für die Spieler ausgegeben, die dann sportlich doch nicht das gebracht haben, was man sich erhofft hat. Dann ist man wieder in die zweite Liga abgestiegen. Zwischendurch zwar auch noch mal hoch in die 1. Liga gekommen, eine super Saison in der 1. Liga gespielt, wieder abgestiegen. Ja, und dann am Ende, das, was niemals jemand für Möglichkeiten hätte, ist man in der 3. Liga gelandet. Und so ist das einfach, ist das eine Folge von Misswirtschaft, die wirklich nach der Meisterschaft 98 begonnen hat, weil man da wirklich glaubte, man kann da jetzt wirklich oben mitspielen über Jahre. Und das zieht sich eben bis jetzt in die heutige Zeit.
Hört sich so an, als hätte man an allen Ecken und Enden Geld ausgegeben. Und dieses Geld fehlt jetzt. Also 12 Millionen. Betzenberg sucht Batzen Geld. Wie will man das jetzt lösen? Du hast schon die drei Modelle angesprochen, dem allen vorausgeht, die Ausgliederung, die schon stattgefunden hat. Und damit wäre ja der Weg für Investoren offen.
Genau, der Weg für Investoren wäre offen. Es ist schön, dass du wäre, sagst. Weil man muss sich ja auch immer überlegen, unter welchen Voraussetzungen würde man denn selbst, zum Beispiel, wenn man Investor ist, wenn man Geld hätte zum Investieren, unter welchen Voraussetzungen wäre man selbst bereit, in einen Verein Geld zu investieren? Zumal man das ja so sehen muss, wenn ich jetzt als außenstehender Investor komme, nicht als Fan. Es gibt ja auch Vereine, wo, sag ich mal, ein Mercedes dahinter steht, der das vielleicht auch vor allem deswegen macht, weil er einfach Interesse an dem Verein hat. Aber ein Investor, im klassischen Sinne, warum investiert er irgendwo?
Naja, der will irgendwann Profit haben.
Der hat ja, wenn er nicht gerade wirklich ein Milliardär ist, der das als Spiel sieht und da so ein bisschen rumspielt mit ein paar Millionen, dann will er da ja irgendwann was rausziehen, angewinnen. Und man fragt sich, wie soll das funktionieren? Wie will man jemals, wenn jemand in den ersten FC Kaiserslautern investiert, wie will dieser Investor jemals damit Profit machen? Und der zweite entscheidende Punkt ist, warum sollte jemand in einen Verein investieren, der in der Außendarstellung völlig pataskopal dasteht? Würdest du einen Verein, der solche Schlagzeilen macht, wie im Moment der FCK, würdest du so einen Verein, selbst wenn du sie hättest, 12 Millionen bzw. noch viel mehr Geld geben? Weil mit den 12 Millionen ist ja gerade mal die nächste Lizenz gesichert. Da sind noch keine neuen Spieler davon verpflichtet. Da ist die Stadionsfrage noch nicht geklärt, weil das spielt in dieser Abwärtsspirale, die ich vorhin erwähnt habe, auch noch eine entscheidende Rolle, weil das Stadion wurde irgendwann verkauft, bzw. musste verkauft werden. Da ist der FCK damals vor der Insolvenz gerettet worden mit 65 Millionen.
Und das Stadion gehört jetzt der Stadt, oder wie war das?
Das Stadion gehört einer städtischen Stadion-Gesellschaft, die eine hundertprozentige Tochter der Stadt ist. Und die Stadt Kaiserslautern, das muss man aufwissen, gehört zu den meistverschuldeten Städten Deutschlands, ist immer so an diesem Ranking in der Top 3 mit unterwegs und hat dieses riesen Stadion, diesen riesen Klotz am Bein, der unglaublich hohe Betriebskosten hat. Wir reden von einem WM-Stadion, das für die WM 2006 noch mal massiv für viele, viele Millionen ausgebaut worden ist, mit einem Fassungsvermögen von fast 50.000 Menschen in der dritten Liga jetzt. Das heißt, dieses Stadion hat Betriebskosten, allein wenn du dieses Stadion aufschließt, nur aufschließt, mit Ordner, Personal, mit Stromkosten, etc., hast du zigtausende Euro, die das jedes Mal kostet, und die Stadt hat das Problem, die sind darauf angewiesen, dass der FCK Miete zahlt. Aber sie müssen natürlich auch darauf schauen, dass der FCK ihnen nicht irgendwann als Mieter komplett ausfällt. Das heißt, sie müssen Kompromisse machen. Das machen sie seit Jahren, indem sie dem FCK Miete stunden, indem der Stadtrat immer mit Mühe und Not das durchboxt, dass der FCK immer weniger und weniger Miete zahlt, so wie jetzt auch in der dritten Liga wurde die Pacht wiederum gesenkt, weil es einfach ansonsten wirtschaftlich für den FCK, der Klamm bei Kasse ist, nicht möglich wäre, dieses Stadion zu finanzieren.
Und wann kippt da die Stimmung in der Bevölkerung der Stadt? Denn das, was man da dem FCK stundet, das fließt ja nicht in, weiß nicht, Grundschulen, Infrastruktur, öffentliche Schwimmbäder und so weiter. Von Kultur bis jetzt gar hier anfangen.
Ja, das ist in der Tat eine Diskussion, die es schon seit vielen Jahren gibt. Und da wurde auch schon von dem einen oder anderen Politiker mal zur Sprache gebracht, dass es dann auch, wenn man den FCK weiter so unterstützt, dazu kommen könnte, dass irgendwann zum Beispiel Kultureinrichtungen weniger unterstützt werden könnten, etc. Der FCK zehrt immer noch sehr, sehr stark von seinen erfolgreichen Jahren. Er zehrt davon, dass die Menschen hier, diesen Verein immer noch, obwohl er sie so oft schon so bitter enttäuscht hat, über alles lieben. Und dass er einen unglaublichen, immer noch vorhandenen Kredit in der Bevölkerung hat. Es gibt ganz viele Menschen, die sagen, ich habe mit FCK und Fußball überhaupt nichts am Hut. Warum geben wir denen so viel Geld? An den vordersten Front übrigens der Oberbürgermeister von Kaiserslautern, der bekennenderweise kein Fußballfan ist, aber sich immer mit dem FCK rumschlagen muss. Und davon zehrt der FCK noch. Aber wir kommen jetzt langsam an den Punkt, wo dieser Kredit verspielt ist. Und das merkst du nicht nur in der Gesamtbevölkerung, sondern speziell auch bei den Fans. Du hast immer mal wieder, wie vorhin auch angesprochen, so kleine Highlights wie z. B der Saisonauftakt mit dem Sieg zu beginnen. Oder jetzt auch nach der Winterpause mit dem Sieg gegen Groß Asbach, 2-0 nach der Winterpause gestartet. Alle sind erst mal wieder zufrieden. Aber du merkst, dass die Stimmung kippt ganz schnell. Die Leute haben es einfach satt. Ich merke es auch bei mir selber. Ich habe das früher mit viel mehr Leidenschaft auch selber verfolgt. Ich muss es natürlich, oder ich verfolge es natürlich weiter mit großem Interesse, auch beruflich. Aber ich habe das früher alles, ich war emotional auch viel näher dran.
Du müsstest jetzt wahrscheinlich länger überlegen, um auf deine 111 Gründe zu kommen, den 1.
Ich sage dir ganz ehrlich, wir machen jetzt gerade eine Neuauflage dieses Buches. Nein, mit noch mal ein paar Bonusgründen. Und die habe ich jetzt soweit eingetütet, aber ich sage dir ganz ehrlich, das war gar nicht so einfach. Da jetzt noch mal neue Gründe zu finden, warum man diesen Verein lieben kann. Natürlich gibt es die und alle eingefleischten FCK-Fans werden diese FCK-Fahnen immer hochhalten und werden sagen, es gibt eine Millionengründe. Aber es fällt einfach immer schwerer und du merkst das im gesamten Umfeld. Wie gesagt, dieser dicke, dicke Kredit, der wirklich noch aus Zeiten Fritz Walters herrührt, da ist noch was da. Das wurde mit den Generationen wirklich weitergegeben, aber so langsam merkst du wirklich, die Leute haben keinen Bock mehr. Und auch wirklich selbst die eingefleischten Fans haben langsam irgendwann die Schnauze voll. Die Stimmung wird immer schlechter bei den Spielen. Es kommen immer wenige Leute ins Stadion. Es ist ein Trauerspiel. Wie gesagt, ein Stadion, wo knapp 50.000 Leute reinpassen. Na ja, wenn da mal 20.000 kommen bei einem Drittligaspiel, ist das viel. Und dann ist dieses Stadion halb leer. Also mehr als halb leer. Und das sieht dann einfach auch trostlos aus. Also ich glaube, dass wir wirklich im Moment an dem Punkt sind, wo die Stimmung tatsächlich kippen kann und vielleicht auch wird. Und es ist jetzt wirklich ganz entscheidend, kriegt der FCK das Geld zusammen? Wenn ja, wie kriegt das zusammen? Spielt er kommende Saison noch in der dritten Liga? Wie werden sie dann das Stadion weiter bezahlen? Weil diese Vereinbarung mit der Stadt gilt jetzt erst mal nur für ein Jahr, für eine Spielzeit. Die Stadt kann es sich eigentlich nicht leisten, diese Pacht fürs Stadion weiterhin zu reduzieren. Die müssen ihrerseits den Kredit bedienen, der damals aufgenommen wurde für das Stadion. Wie gesagt, 65 Millionen. Das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Der ist übrigens auch irgendwann nochmal fällig. Also das ist ein Teufelskreis, das kann man sich eigentlich nicht vorstellen.
Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, wenn wir mit den roten Teufeln sprechen. Aber damit sind wir ja dann, also wir haben glaube ich dann ganz gut so das Fundament jetzt gelegt, das ehrlich gesagt etwas löchrige und verrottete Fundament für die aktuelle Krise. Aber wir haben ja noch nicht ganz beantwortet, warum zum Beispiel der Hauptsponsor bei Facebook zu solchen Worten greift, für die er sich dann im Nachgang noch entschuldigt hat. Aber es hat ja jetzt im aktuellen Fall wieder gerappelt. Und wir haben jetzt schon vor ein paar Tagen geschrieben und zwischendurch sah es so aus, als könnte der Aufsichtsratsboss komplett entmachtet werden, was dann tatsächlich nicht geschehen ist. Patrick Banff ist der Aufsichtsratsboss. Was ist denn jetzt der konkrete Anlass jetzt, also wir wissen, die 12 Millionen braucht es, aber warum ist man sich so uneinig? Worüber ist man sich denn uneinig?
Da sind wir wieder bei der Frage, wo soll das Geld herkommen, diese 12 Millionen, und da sind wir bei dem Punkt Investor. Und man ist sich im Aufsichtsratsbund eigentlich darüber, welcher Investor da in Frage kommen könnte, oder man zieht da nicht an einem Strang.
Also gibt es aber Investoren, die tatsächlich ein Interesse am FCK hätten?
Möglicherweise. Der Name Ponomareff ist immer wieder gefallen, er ist ja kein Unbekannter.
Er engagiert sich ja auch mit dabei und bei den Gräfer der Pinguinen.
Genau, und früher mal bei der Düsseldorfer EG. Dieser Name ist gefallen, da hat einer aus dem Aufsichtsrat offenbar versucht, da in Kontakt herzustellen. Und angeblich hatte er wohl auch Interesse, sich auch beim FCK zu engagieren. Das hat dann wiederum dem Aufsichtsratsvorsitzenden Banff nicht geschmeckt, und man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, es geht im Aufsichtsrat nicht unbedingt nur darum, wirklich das Beste für den FCK im Moment rauszufinden oder hinzubekommen, sondern man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, jeder möchte am Ende derjenige sein, der sich hinstellen kann und kann sagen, hier, Leute, ich habe den und den Investor an Land gezogen, der gibt uns das und das Geld, und damit habe ich jetzt quasi den 1. FC Kaiserslautern gerettet. Und weil die sich einfach untereinander nicht einig sind, sondern alle so ein bisschen ihr eigenes Ding machen, herrschen da einfach Eitelkeiten und die kommen irgendwie, warum auch immer, nach draußen. Das darf eigentlich so nicht sein. Ich glaube, in jedem Aufsichtsgrad von jedem Verein oder was auch immer von einem Konzern, da kracht es sicher mal. Aber professionell wäre es natürlich, das Ganze hinter verschlossenen Türen zu halten und diesen Streit nicht nach außen auszutragen. Ich meine, es kann ja nicht sein, dass kurz vor einer Aufsichtsgrad-Sitzung, das heißt, okay, heute soll wahrscheinlich der Aufsichtsgrad-Sitz und von den anderen abgesägt werden. Normalerweise darf so was niemals vorher nach draußen kommen. Klar, wir wissen ja alle, wie das Geschäft funktioniert. Irgendwie kommt es dann doch noch raus. Aber es ist ein Unding, dass dann diese Sitzung stattfindet, also stattgefunden hat, mit dem Ergebnis, dass es kein Ergebnis gibt, dass sich quasi nichts verändert, dass der Aufsichtsgrad-Vorsitzende im Amt bleibt und dass man jetzt erst mal versuchen will, gemeinsam für den FCK die beste Lösung zu finden, sprich, irgendwie diese Finanzlücke zu schließen und dass man sich dann im Anschluss noch mal hinsetzen möchte, um zu prüfen, ob da wirklich die Führungspositionen, sage ich mal, richtig verteilt sind. Und da, ja, wie gesagt, es geht um Eitelkeiten. Es geht um Eitelkeiten, die nach draußen getragen werden und warum sich dann auch noch schlussendlich der Hauptsponsor mit einmischt. Auf diese Art und Weise hat er da auch irgendwie so ein, ich glaube, ein Taschentuch, ein verrotztes Taschentuch, oder was das war, was er da gepostet hat. Also, das ist dann schon, ja, muss man sich fragen, ob es das dann wirklich auch noch bringt. Auf der einen Seite wünschen sich die Fans in Kaiserslautern natürlich einen Hauptsponsor, der wirklich mit Feuer dabei ist, der selber auch Fan ist, und das ist Harald Leinberger, absolut. Und er ist auch total akzeptiert, obwohl er sich ja auch als Hauptsponsor noch bei Union Berlin engagiert. Aber er kommt hier aus der Gegend, er ist FCK-Fan, er brennt dafür, du merkst das, er hat wirklich große, große Sympathien für den Verein. Aber ob es wirklich Aufgabe eines Hauptsponsors ist, sich dann öffentlich auf Facebook zu äußern und den Aufsichtstraat zu kritisieren, ob das dann wirklich so zuträglich ist der Gesamtsituation, das sei mal dahingestellt.
Na ja, er spricht halt für eine gewisse Hilflosigkeit und dass halt da auch kommunikativ so einiges aus den Fugen geraten ist. Aber dann lass mal bei Michael Ponomarev bleiben. Also wir haben schon erwähnt, dass er auch beim KFC Uerdingen involviert ist. Deshalb dürfte er auch nur bis zu einer gewissen Grenze beim 1. FC Kaiserslautern einsteigen, würde damit aber fast exakt die 12 Millionen Euro-Lücke schließen, die man für die Lizenz eben bis, ich glaube, Mitte März braucht. Ansonsten gingen die Lichter vielleicht sogar ganz aus auf dem Betzenberg. Wenn wir uns jetzt mal lösen, wir können das ja tun. Wir können uns ja davon lösen, von der Frage, wer hat den jetzt kontaktiert und finden wir das jetzt toll, dass das ein Alleingang war von einem Aufsichtsrat oder finden wir das nicht gut. Welche Argumente würden denn dafür und dagegen sprechen, mit Ponomarev ins Boot zu steigen oder ihn ins Boot zu holen? Hat denn der FCK überhaupt eine Wahl?
Der FCK hat keine Wahl. Eigentlich muss der FCK jeden nehmen, der ein bisschen Kohle hat und helfen kann. Ganz einfach. Dafür spricht, dass der Mann Kohle hat, dafür spricht, dass er vielleicht kein ganz Ahnungsloser ist, was das Fußballgeschäft angeht. Er ist ja, wie gesagt, in Oerdingen auch aktiv. Dagegen könnte sprechen, dass er über kurz oder lang zu viel Einfluss nehmen will. In Oerdingen ist er ja auch Präsident. Das heißt, da kann er, wie man hört, schalten und walten, wie er möchte. Und das ist halt die Frage, wie viel Einfluss möchte man haben durch so einen externen Investor? Man hat sich da zwar seitens des FCK bei der Ausliederung insofern abgesichert, dass ein Investor nur ein gewisses Mitspracherecht hat. Aber ja, es ist halt wirklich die Frage, möchte man so jemanden im Verein haben oder nicht? Und wie ich ja vorhin auch schon erwähnt habe, Herr von der Marbeff war ja auch schon bei der Düsseldorfer EG aktiv im Eishockey und ist dann da auch nicht so ganz friedlich ausgeschieden, angeblich Gelder, die noch versprochen waren, sind nicht gezahlt worden und so weiter. Ja, es ist halt ein russischer Investor. Es ist halt die Frage, inwieweit möchte man sich auf einen russischen Investor einlassen, welches Ziel hat er, welches Ziel verfolgt er? Das ist ja die Frage. Ist es für ihn vielleicht einfach ein Hobby, eine Art Spielball und könnte es dann vielleicht auch sein, dass er den FCK dann irgendwann wieder fallen lässt, wenn er überhaupt keine Lust mehr drauf hat? Oder worauf muss man sich einstellen? Aber wie ich anfangs schon sagte, man hat eigentlich auch nicht die Wahl. Man hat nicht die Wahl, man muss eigentlich denjenigen nehmen, der das Geld hat. Aber gerade im Fall von Bruno Marbeff kommt ja dazu, dass er das dementiert, dass er gar nicht einsteigen will. Ja, er hat das dementiert. Und jetzt gerade, ich habe gerade vor zwei Tagen auch wieder was gelesen, dass er jetzt bei Ueding auch noch mal kräftig weitermacht. Und sie planen da auch gemeinsam mit der Stadt Uedingen eine GmbH zu gründen, um dann ein neues Stadion zu bauen, beziehungsweise das Stadion zu sanieren, glaube ich. Also der will da wirklich noch mal fett Geld investieren in Ueding. Und also warum sollte er das dann bei einem Liga-Konkurrenten auch noch machen? Ich meine, klar, Ueding hat Ambitionen aufzusteigen. Und ich glaube, ja, die Chance ist da.
Klar, sind ja auch von der fünften Liga jetzt bis in die dritte Durchmarsch.
Ja, also der Durchmarsch in die zweite ist durchaus denkbar. Und er hat das jetzt mehrfach dementiert. Also er wurde zwar jeweils immer nur von anderen Medien zitiert. Ich habe es in nicht selber sagen hören, aber er hat das dementiert.
Also reden wir hier vielleicht auch über eine Ente, oder?
Wir reden vielleicht auch über eine Ente. Andererseits gab es Kollegen beim SWR, die die Info hatten. Und dass es wohl eine Absichtserklärung gebe, die er unterzeichnet hätte, mit der er die Absicht hat, beim FCK tatsächlich einzusteigen. Aber ich weiß nicht, ist es dann ein Spiel, das dann öffentlich zu dementieren? Oder warum sollte er es dementieren, wenn es wirklich so ist?
Also es würde zwar irgendwie ganz gut passen, wenn er jetzt dann trotzdem einsteigen würde, kurz nach seinem Dementi. Also würde so zur Kommunikationskultur des ersten FCK dann doch passen, aber schon ein bisschen komisch. Gibt es denn noch weitere Alternativen? Ich habe noch von einem Flavio Becker gelesen.
Genau, also man muss dir sagen, so wenig wie der FCK momentan Fußballer-geschmö mit dem internationalen Geschäft zu tun hat, so bewegt er sich zumindest bei der Investoren-Suche international, nämlich wir haben einmal...
Na die Deutschen, die kennen den FCK einfach zu gut, weißt du.
Wir haben einmal Russland im Spiel mit Herrn von Nomarev, über den wir gerade gesprochen haben und eben Herrn Becker aus Luxemburg und dann gibt es auch noch eine Art Konsortium aus der Schweiz, was wohl auch noch Interesse hat. Es ist im Moment ganz, ganz schwer zu sagen, was wirklich dran ist. Herr Becker ist ein sehr reicher Mensch aus Luxemburg. Luxemburg, was ja auch nicht wirklich weit weg von hier ist, von Kaiserslautern und Luxemburg, wo auch der FCK traditionell eine Bindung zu hat. Ich erinnere da an Jeff Strasser, der ja auch gar nicht allzu lange Zeit Trainer beim FCK war, dann leider ausgeschieden ist aus gesundheitlichen Gründen. Und traditionell gibt es tatsächlich einige Fans und auch Fanclubs in Luxemburg. Also die Verbindung FCK Luxemburg, die ist auf jeden Fall gegeben. Und Herr Becker hat wohl auch sich schon so weit geäußert, dass er den FCK interessant findet. Inwiefern das jetzt wirklich konkret ist, das lässt sich im Moment schwer abschätzen. Er ist wohl im Gespräch, er ist noch im Spiel. Ob das wirklich jetzt zu einem konkreten Investment kommt, das steht in den Sternen. Er engagiert sich ja auch noch in Düdelingen, die ja auch einen bekannten deutschen Trainer haben, Dino Topmeller. Das heißt, da hat er auch noch einen zweiten Verein oder einen ersten Verein, bei dem er sich schon engagiert. Ist die Frage, will er das dann auch in Deutschland machen? Aber auf der wäre zumindest kein unbeschriebenes Blatt und hätte zumindest auch so ein bisschen Ahnung von Fußball. Er weiß, was er macht und er wird auch hier, habe ich gerade vorhin noch mal einen Artikel nachgelesen, wo eben dieser von mir gerade eben schon angeführte Dino Topmeller sagt, wenn der Bäcker was macht, dann macht das richtig. Das heißt, wenn er irgendwo anpackt, dann wird es auch was.
Klar, Düdelingen ist ja sensationell in die Europa League eingezogen, hat dagegen Bielern mal geführt zwischenzeitlich 2 zu 1. Es gibt allerdings jetzt auch Meldungen, nach denen es heißt, weil er kein neues Stadion bauen dürfe und er ist eben jemand, der sehr gerne Dinge baut. Bäcker, der Baumeister, habe ich da gelesen in einem Artikel. Spiele er eben mit dem Gedanken, sein Engagement da gleich wieder zu beenden, was natürlich zum einen die Tür vielleicht für den 1. FC Kaiserslautern öffnet, zum anderen aber auch zeigt, so schnell wie er wo reingeht, geht er vielleicht auch wieder raus und das ist ja dann wiederum einer der Risikofaktoren, den man eben einfach hat, wenn man sich auf Investoren einlassen muss, so wie es jetzt bei FCK aussieht.
Und das sind wir ja auch wieder bei dem Punkt, wir reden die ganze Zeit über diese 12 Millionen, aber um den FCK über längere Sicht wieder auf gesunde finanzielle Beine zu stellen, müssten da ja weitaus mehr als 12 Millionen fließen. Also ich glaube, da reden wir von jährlich dieser Summe plus. Also ich glaube, wenn man da nicht jährlich mindestens, keine Ahnung, 20 Millionen investiert, dann kommt man da auf lange Sicht gesehen nicht weiter. Und eigentlich musst du sogar noch den Schritt weitergehen und musst sagen, du musst einen Investor finden, der irgendwie dir hilft, diese Stadion zurückzukaufen. Beziehungsweise der für dich das Stadion kauft, was ja auch immer wieder im Gespräch ist, nicht nur das Stadion, sondern auch das Gelände drumherum zu kaufen. Das ist ein etwas größeres Areal, könnte auch kein schlechtes Bauland sein, das ist wirklich an exponierter Stelle in Kaiserslautern auf dem Berg, wer schon mal da war, der weiß es, dass der Betzenberg nicht nur Bund-Betzenberg heißt. Und das ist eben eine der Überlegungen, dass ein Investor hingehen könnte, könnte das ganze Gelände kaufen, auch das, was um das Stadion drumherum liegt, und könnte das noch entsprechend verwerten und könnte da noch Baugrundstücke etc. draus machen.
Aber das wäre auch eine Überlegung. Das würde mich jetzt interessieren, ist das denn wirklich attraktiv, denn das, was ich so über Kaiserslautern jetzt von dir gehört habe, zur Verschuldung der Stadt und was ich noch so selbst an Infrastruktur in Erinnerung habe, ist Kaiserslautern ein attraktiver Standort für, was könnte man da hinbauen, natürlich Wohnungen, man könnte im Hotel-Gastronomie-Bereich gehen. Wie ist es denn um die Region gerade bestellt?
Die Region ist auf alle Fälle attraktiv in einem sehr bestimmten Bereich. Wir sind hier ein sehr starker IT- und Wissenschaftsstandort. Wir haben hier eine sehr renommierte technische Universität. Wir haben eine Fachhochschule. Wir haben unglaublich viel Fachpersonal aus dem IT-Bereich, Software-Entwickler, Fraunhofer-Institut. Wir haben das Deutsche Forschungszentrum für Künstliche Intelligenz hier. Wir haben wirklich ganz viele Forschungszentren, etc., PP-Entwickler hier und die machen den Standort wirklich in diesem Bereich sehr interessant. Das ist auch ein Grund, warum zum Beispiel auch zwei Hotels noch mal neu gebaut worden sind oder eins ist immer noch im Bau, direkt am Messeplatz, auch unweit des Stadions, weil es die Nachfrage nach Übernachtung auch gibt in der Stadt. Das heißt, Kaiserslautern, muss man sich so vorstellen, war früher klassischerweise eine Industriestadt. Wir hatten hier eine große Spinnerei, die Camgarn. Wir hatten hier den größten oder bekanntesten Nähmaschinenhersteller mit Pfaff. Das sind alles Unternehmen, die mittlerweile leider nicht mehr oder nur noch in einem bestimmten, kleineren Rahmen existieren. Das waren früher Tausende von Arbeitsplätzen, die mit dem Bankrott dieser Firmen natürlich verloren gegangen sind. Wir haben hier immer noch einen Opelberg. Hier werden immer noch Teile von Opel-Autos gefertigt. Da ist die Frage, wie lange noch? Aber das unterstreicht auch nochmal Kaiserslautern, war und ist zu Teilen immer noch ein Industriestandort. Aber weil das immer weniger wird, gibt es natürlich auch auf der anderen Seite immer mehr arbeitslose Leute, die eben in diesen Bereichen gearbeitet haben und da jetzt nichts mehr finden. Aber im krassen Gegensatz dazu haben wir eben diesen Technologie-Standort Kaiserslautern, der sich eben so krass spezialisiert hat auf diese Dinge, auch Informatik etc. Also da ist auf jeden Fall der Bedarf, denke ich, da. Und auch, ich glaube, der Bedarf am Wohnraum ist nach wie vor da und auch an modernen Büroflächen. Das heißt, ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass man das vermarktet bekommt, zumal auch in einer Stadt wie Kaiserslautern, das nicht spurlos vorübergeht, dass, sage ich mal, momentan die Zinsen noch relativ niedrig sind und viele, viele Leute bauen wollen. Gerade auch in einer Stadt wie Kaiserslautern. Ich meine, das muss ich dir nicht sagen. Du wohnst in München, du kennst wahrscheinlich die Immobilienpreise in München. Dafür, also für den Preis, wo du in München irgendwie ein halbes Zimmer bekommst, kannst du hier schon ein Einfamilienhaus bauen, um es jetzt mal übertrieben darzustellen. Das heißt, es ist für die Leute auf jeden Fall auch interessant, immer noch hier zu wohnen. Und du hast schlussendlich auch noch eine hohe Lebensqualität, weil du hier sehr naturverbunden bist, auch mit dem Pfälzer Wald drumherum. Das heißt, Kaiserslautern ist trotz der vielen auch aufgezählten negativen Punkte immer noch eine attraktive Stadt.
Okay, und das ist ja dann vielleicht auch ein Argument für so ein Schweizer Konsortium, dass man sich da engagiert. Weil gerade dieser Baulandaspekt und eben diese Stadionfrage und dass man eben auch weiß, dass die Stadt da nicht in einer Situation ist, wo sie entspannt ist und sagt, ne, klar, wir wollen das jetzt auf jeden Fall behalten, sondern die wären sehr, sehr dankbar, wenn da jemand Geld auf den Tisch legt und sagt, wir kaufen das jetzt zurück und wollen da oben noch ein bisschen was investieren. Macht das ja alles zu einer guten Konstellation. Weiß man denn, wer hinter diesem Konsortium steckt? Wer ist das? Ja, das ist ja schon mal wieder vertrauenserweckend.
Das wüsste ich sehr, sehr gerne. Ja gut, ich meine, wie das halt immer so ist. Ich meine, wir reden da ja wirklich über einige Millionen, wie gesagt, damals hatte das Ganze im Volumen von 65 Millionen mit dem Stadion. Ich kann jetzt nicht genau sagen, was ein Investor dann wirklich zahlen müsste, wenn er dieses ganze Areal da oben übernehmen will. Aber dass man da vielleicht auch erst mal wartet, bis man sich wirklich ganz, ganz sicher ist, ob man das tut oder nicht, ob man da investiert, dass man da eben wartet, bis man sich outet, ist, glaube ich, auch irgendwo klar. Aber es wird auch immer wieder gemunkelt, beziehungsweise ist wohl tatsächlich auch so, dass dieses Konsortium wohl schon mehrere 100.000 Euro in die Planungen investiert hat. Das heißt, das spricht auch dafür, dass dieser Standort da oben tatsächlich relativ interessant ist. Aber wer da jetzt genau dahinter steckt, ich wüsste es auch gerne, zumal es jetzt langsam auch echt mal Zeit wird. Wir haben jetzt Ende Januar, März müssen die Unterlagen für die Lizenz abgegeben werden. Bis dahin muss dieses Finanzloch irgendwie geschlossen werden. Und ich kann beim besten Willen noch nicht erkennen, wie das passieren soll.
Das bringt uns dann vielleicht auch zu der etwas schmerzhaften und leicht spekulativen Frage, was würde denn im Fall der Fälle passieren?
Du meinst, wenn das Geld nicht kommt? Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass man auch wenn das ein ganz ganz furchtbarer Gedanke ist für viele Leute und dass das für viele auch total weit weg ist immer noch, dass man sich mit dem Worst Case beschäftigen muss.
Dass es den Verein danach nicht mehr gibt?
Dass es den Verein in der bestehenden Form vielleicht danach nicht mehr gibt. Ich meine, es gibt ja auch Beispiele von Vereinen, die, sag ich mal, einige Etagen tiefer in Neustart gewagt haben, 60 München zum Beispiel. Wobei die ja auch, sag ich mal, einen Herrn als Geldgeber haben, der durchaus streitbar ist. Also ich habe tatsächlich arge Bedenken, dass es für den FCK in dieser Konstellation, wie sie momentan ist, weitergeht. Also ich sehe es einfach nicht, dass die es jetzt in der Zeit gebacken bekommen. Und selbst wenn sie jetzt, nehmen wir mal an, wir hatten es ja vorhin auch schon von der Möglichkeit der Zwischenfinanzierung, nehmen wir mal diesen Fall an und sie schaffen jetzt irgendwie eine Zwischenfinanzierung auf die Beine zu stellen, dann schiebt das das Problem ja nur auf. Das heißt, dieses Problem, dass der FCK kein Geld hat, ist ja nach wie vor da. Nur wenn man jetzt irgendwie irgendwelche Zwischenkredite aufnimmt, um dieses kurzfristige Finanzloch zu stopfen, schafft man sich ja wiederum ein Finanzloch in der Zukunft. Es würde allerdings auch nochmal ein bisschen Zeit bringen, um tatsächlich einen passenden Investor zu finden. Es ist ja aber auch so, man muss sich das ja auch mal klammern, es kann ja nicht nur ein großer Investor, ein sogenannter Anker-Investor, wie es beim FCK immer heißt, einsteigen. Es können auch Fans demnächst einsteigen oder Firmen, ab einem Volumen von 100.000 Euro. Also ich habe jetzt noch nicht allzu viele Vollzugsmeldungen gehört von Firmen oder sonstigen Institutionen, die da groß Geld investieren wollen in den FCK. Weil da sind wir ja wieder bei dem Punkt, als Investor, wenn ich nicht vereinsnah bin, investiere ich, weil ich da irgendwann eine Rendite rausholen will. Die Leute, die dem Verein nahestehen und die das Geld hätten, um ihn zu unterstützen, ich glaube, die wären schon längst da. Weil dieses Problem besteht nicht erst seit gestern, dass der FCK Geld braucht. Und wenn es wirklich irgendwo einen oder mehrere Leute gäbe, denen der FCK am Herzen liegt und die das Geld hätten, ihn zu unterstützen, dann glaube ich, wären die schon längst da. Selbst ein Harald-Leinberger, der jetzt Hauptsponsor ist, der ist auch kein armer Mann, aber der hat jetzt auch nicht, der unterstützt natürlich den FCK mit seinem Sponsoring. Aber auch er hat sich da jetzt, glaube ich, seitens der hat es mittlerweile getan, noch nicht anderweitig noch größer engagiert finanziell. Das heißt, ich glaube einfach nicht dran, dass es irgendwo noch jemanden gibt, der da jetzt um die Ecke kommt und sagt, zack, hier ist die Rettung. Also du merkst...
Und die Politik kann sich das wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr erlauben. Also in der großen Zeit, in der Kurt Beck da irgendwelche anteilseigner Versammlungen oder Mitgliederversammlungen geführt hat, die Zeiten sind ja auch vorbei.
Die Zeiten sind vorbei. Auf Kurt Beck wird auch immer noch sehr, sehr viel geschimpft. Deswegen, Kurt Beck war bekennender FCK-Fan, da hat sich natürlich da wirklich reingehängt, hat den FCK damals augenscheinlich gerettet, hat ihm aber durch diese Stadionlösungen neue Probleme eingebockt, die jetzt wieder einholen. Und ich glaube, da muss man sich keine Illusion hingeben, dass die Politik da groß unterstützen wird. Man muss natürlich aber auf der anderen Seite auch sagen, die Politik hat natürlich auch entscheidend dazu beigetragen, dass diese Stadionausbau überhaupt gekommen ist, dass Kaiserslautern als WM-Staat präsent war. Das hat man natürlich in der Landespolitik, in Rheinland-Pfalz, fand man das auch geil. Muss man ja mal ganz klar sagen.
Ja, der FCK wurde immer eher auf Händen getragen. Das ist ja auch das, was viele Fans anderer Vereine, die nicht aus dieser Region kommen, durchaus kritisch sehen.
Ja, man konnte sich damit brüsten. Man konnte sagen, Mensch, der tolle FCK, Kaiserslautern, wir sind WM-Standort. Und jeder, der die WM damals hier in Kaiserslautern erlebt hat, ich bin einer der glücklich, in der sie erlebt hat, das waren die geilsten, das war der geilste Monat, die geilsten vier Wochen, die es in Kaiserslautern nie gab. Aber in ganz Deutschland, jeder, der die WM damals erlebt hat, das Wetter war toll, die Stimmung war toll. Die Stadt hat sich super präsentiert. Und alle sagen, stimmungsmäßig und so gefühlsmäßig war das ein Riesengewinn. Aber eben mit schmerzhaften finanziellen Folgen für den FCK jetzt im Nachhinein. Und da muss man wie gesagt sagen, da hat natürlich die Politik auch ihren Beitrag dazu geleistet, dass den FCK oder die Stadt, sag ich mal, angeschoben oder das zu tun. Aber trotzdem glaube ich nicht, dass wir da auf Rückendeckung der Politik oder zumindest der Landespolitik hoffen, dass wir da auf den Weg laufen sollten. Die Stadtpolitik hilft dem FCK ja so gut es geht immer wieder, wie ich ja schon angesprochen habe.
Ja, das ist ja auch so eine, zwar irgendwie eine abusive relationship, aber es ist ja schon noch eine Beziehung zwischen den beiden. Es war keine gesunde, genau, man kann nicht ohne einander, man muss irgendwie miteinander. Und deswegen muss man da ja auch irgendwie miteinander dann versuchen, das Ganze am Leben zu halten. Aber der Worst-Case wäre ja, wenn wir jetzt mal ausschließen, dass auch der DFB sagt, ach komm, dann nehmen wir das mit den Lizenz-Auflagen mal nicht so eng, würde ich jetzt mal ausschließen in dem Fall, dann lief es ja auf eine Insolvenz heraus und dann, wie tief würde dann eigentlich lautern fallen? Also ich habe jetzt noch mal nachgeguckt, Alemannia Aachen ist ja gerade in der Regionalliga West, die haben ja 2017 die zweite Insolvenz angemeldet. Bei 1860 war es damals auch so, dass dann gleich der Bayerische Fußballverband, der für die Regionalligen zuständig ist, dann gesagt hat, also da würden wir natürlich noch einen Platz schaffen, zur Not machen wir noch einen zusätzlichen Startplatz, alles gar kein Problem.
Gut, das ist Bayern, das ergänzt ein anderes Gesetz.
Ja gut, da wäre jetzt hier mit Rheinland-Pfalz, also was würde das bedeuten?
Ja auch da müsste ich natürlich in die Glaskugel schauen, die ich nicht habe, aber ich könnte mir Regionalliga vorstellen, könnte auch Oberliga werden. Da bin ich nicht derjenige, der das wirklich prophezeien kann. Aber ja, also ich denke mal Regionalliga, Oberliga würde es dann beim FCK sicher auch werden. Ja und dann müsste man eben sehen, ob und wie schnell man da wieder rauskommt. Das ist natürlich auch, das ist, man hätte ja einen ganzen Ratten-Schwanz nach sich. Weil wie soll man in einem Spielbetrieb, in der Regionale oder der Oberliga, wie soll man dieses Stadion finanzieren?
Das ist eigentlich unmöglich.
Das ist eigentlich unmöglich. Aber auch in dem Fall könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass dann wieder mal einer dieser Buckel, was ist die Depp-Lokal von Ruck, durch die Fanszene geht und dass dann irgendwie 30.000, 40.000 in die Regionalliga oder in die Oberliga gehen. Ich meine, bei 60 war es ja auch so, die Fanbase war auch nach dem Absturz noch da.
Aber die hatten halt einen anderen Stadionfaktor, weißt du? Die sind halt einfach zurück ins Grünwalder.
Ins Grünwalder, was ohnehin die bessere Entscheidung für 60 ist.
Genau, also da kommt dann quasi zu dem, und auswärts waren bei denen trotzdem in Anführungszeichen nur 500 mit dabei oder 200, und zu besonderen Spielen immer mehr. Aber da hatte quasi dieser Stadionfaktor noch was anderes. Bei euch ist das Stadion ja ein Teil des Rucksackes, den man die ganze Zeit schon mit sich rumträgt. Und so mytisch der Betzenberg einst war. Also ich war das letzte Mal, als ich bei Lautern war, das war gegen Union, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 27. Spieltag, zweite Liga, es ging um nichts mehr. Und da waren dann auch so 20 oder, ich glaube sogar, nur wenige da. Ich war damals noch sehr enttäuscht, wie wenig Leute da waren. Und da hatte, ehrlich gesagt, dieser komplette Betzenberg, der hatte nichts von dem, was den Betzenberg eigentlich ausmacht. Und das ist ja eigentlich die Realität, nicht mehr der Mythos, den es mal gab mit den Rentnern, die irgendwelche Linienrichterassistenten mit ihren Regenschirmen pieksen.
Genau. Und das hatten wir zum letzten Mal 2013 in der Relegation gegen Hoffenheim. Dieses typische Betze-Feeling, dieses typische alle brennen für die Jungs auf dem Rasen und die Rentner packen den Regenschirm auf und hindern den gegnerischen Spieler am Einwurf oder wie auch immer. Das ist tatsächlich nicht von gestern, das muss man so sagen. Also die Stimmung in diesem pompösen Stadion, was es ja ohne Zweifel ist, die ist spätestens jetzt, was das angeht, in der dritten Liga angekommen. Also da braucht man sich wirklich nichts vormachen. Die Bastion Betzenberg, die gab es früher mal, aber die ist jetzt keine Bastion mehr. Und dieser wirklich entscheidende Vorteil, den der FCK früher immer hatte, zu Hause eine Macht zu sein. Man hat ja auch immer gesagt, in Lautern wird so lange gespielt, bis der FCK gewonnen hat. Und nicht nur ein Tor ist irgendwie in der 93. oder 94. Minute gefallen. Ich erinnere mich da auch an eine Schlagzeile typisch Lautern, Ramsey trifft, ich glaube in der 94. Minute damals zum 3-2 gegen Gladbach. Also das war früher so, aber da sind wir jetzt lange nicht mehr. Und jeder, der in letzter Zeit mal bei einem Spiel war, und ich muss sagen, ich war jetzt beim letzten Spiel seit langem, langem mal wieder nicht, weil ich Papa geworden bin, aber ansonsten wirklich bei allen Spielen davor. Und es ist ein Grauen, das zu sehen. Es tut einem wirklich weh, wie sich auch die Stimmung entwickelt hat, weil wir eben da wieder bei dem Punkt sind, dass selbst die härtesten der harten Fans so langsam ein bisschen resigniert haben. Das werden wahrscheinlich jetzt viele wieder bestreiten, weil sie sagen, an Gottes Willen, wir lassen doch den FC Kaiserslautern gar nicht im Stich, aber man muss sich noch mal die Zuschauerzahlen anschauen, man muss sich noch mal auf die Tribüne stellen und sich mal die Stimmung anschauen.
Ja, in den letzten sechs kompletten Spielzeiten war das Stadion genau zweimal ausverkauft. Das hört sich alles ziemlich dramatisch an. Wir werden jetzt einfach abwarten, was bis Mitte März ist, glaube ich, ist die Deadline. Was da passieren wird, ob man einen Investor aus dem Hut zaubern kann, welcher Investor das sein wird und ob sich da noch andere mit dranhängen, wenn es diesen Anker-Investor, diesen Begriff habe ich auch erst im Umgang mit dem 1. FC Kaiserslautern gelernt, wenn es diesen Anker-Investor gibt. Und dann gibt es ja noch das ganze Sportliche. Darüber haben wir jetzt ja gar nicht gesprochen. Das ist ja eigentlich der Irrsinn des FCK, der das aber auch so ganz gut zusammenfasst, die aktuelle Situation.
Also, man muss sagen, ganz, ganz viele Leute waren auch froh, dass jetzt die Winterpause vorbei war und dass mal wieder Fußball gespielt wurde. Weil das ist ja das, worum es eigentlich geht, klar, dass alles, worüber wir uns jetzt unterhalten haben, das ist die Basis, ohne das funktioniert es nicht. Aber am Ende geht es immer noch um den Fußball.
Und da wurde viel zu wenig drüber gesprochen.
Wir haben in Kaiserslautern nur noch Themen Geld und Investoren-Suche und das war es. Inzwischen hatten wir mal die Cornflakes-Affäre, das war auch ganz nett. Aber sportlich hat es uns auch nicht wirklich was gebracht. Und es ist echt so, dass ganz, ganz viele Leute, mich eingeschlossen, jetzt einfach auch froh sind, dass wieder Fußball gespielt wird. Und jetzt hoffen wir halt auch drauf oder hoffen die Fans drauf, dass die Verantwortlichen eben im Hintergrund ihre Arbeit machen, die Spieler auf dem Platz ihre Arbeit machen. Und dann muss man eben sehen, was dabei rauskommt. Die Spieler werden jetzt versuchen, ihr Bestes zu geben, um sich sportlich so gut wie möglich zu platzieren. Wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht dran, dass sie nochmal ein Wörtchen mitreden können um den Aufstieg. Lass mich da aber gerne Lügen strafen und eines Besseren belehren und wir unterhalten uns gerne Ende der Saison nochmal und ich gebe einen aus, weil ich den FCK abgeschrieben habe, aber sie es doch noch geschafft haben. Das ist das eine und das andere ist, wie gesagt, dass die Vereinsverantwortlichen jetzt ihren Job machen. Es ist ja sowieso ohnehin die Frage, wir haben vorhin über den Aufsichtsrat gesprochen, inwiefern ist es überhaupt der Job eines Aufsichtsrats, einen Investor zu suchen. Ich meine, wie der Name schon sagt, der Aufsichtsrat, der führt Aufsicht über das, was da eigentlich passiert und sollte vielleicht eher gucken, ob die Deals, die da jemand an Land zieht, ob die wasserfest sind, ob die Verträge in Ordnung sind und nicht selber noch suchen. Andererseits ist es vielleicht auch nicht schlecht, aufgrund der geringen Zeit, die noch bleibt, dass auch die Aufsichtsräte sich da engagieren. Man will ihnen das Bemühen nicht absprechen, aber alle, alle, alle täten wirklich gut daran, sich jetzt mal zusammenzureißen und zu gucken, dass sie es bestmöglich für den FCK rausholen und ihre Streitigkeit mal beiseite zu legen. Und die können sich am Ende der Saison immer noch fetzen.
Es ist ein frommer Wunsch, möchte ich sagen. Alle weiteren Kommentare zu Prognosen erspare ich mir dann. Und dann werden wir es ja sehen, Sebastian. Und es ist auf jeden Fall schön zu hören, dass es dennoch eine zweite Auflage geben wird, der 111 Gründe, den 1. FC Kaiserslautern zu lieben. Und dann können wir auch gespannt sein. Vielleicht kommt ja dann noch als weiterer Grund irgendein Wunder-Investor mit dazu. Vielleicht einer, den wir noch gar nicht genannt haben, der das Ganze tatsächlich nur aus Spaß an der Freude macht und keine Rendite möchte. Ach, das wäre doch schön. Dann hätte sich ja die Ausgliederung sogar irgendwie gelohnt. Das haben wir jetzt ja gar nicht thematisiert. Ja, Sebastian, ich danke dir. Bei Twitter kann man dir folgen als attwitcherydu mit 3o hinten dran. Also attwitcherydu. Ich verlinke es natürlich auch hier unter der Folge. Ist vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher. Sebastian Zobel vom SWR. Vielen lieben Dank dir, Sebastian. Und Glückwunsch nochmal nachträglich zur Vaterschaft.
Und ich bin auch wirklich froh, dass wir heute deinen Video-Podcast aufgezeichnet haben. Von daher vielen Dank, dass wir uns heute auf Audio beschränkt haben.
Ja, Augenringe bis zu den Fußnägeln, das erkenne ich. Und danke dir umso mehr, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast. Und dann bin ich mal gespannt. Wir werden das weiter verfolgen. Und spätestens im März gibt es ja dann die nächsten Schlagzeilen. Und dann werden wir sehen, ob es der 1. FC Kaiserslautern mal wieder schafft, irgendwie seinen Kopf aus der Schlinge zu ziehen. Oder ob dann vielleicht doch zumindest kurzzeitig mal wirtschaftlich die Lichter so ausgehen, dass man einen bitteren Gang in untere Liegen antreten muss. Einen noch bitteren Gang. Sebastian, danke dir. Bis bald. Mal wieder. Mach's gut.